A little while back I saw a reddit post and linked
article, both written by Joshua Wood, and it went
something like this—Brackets are a useful tool,
but they have limitations. They do cover power
level to some extent, but they don’t address
specific play pattern preferences aside from
following general community preferences such as
limitations on mana denial in lower brackets. A
good solution to this problem is to have
players come to the table with a basic 10
second pitch for what their deck is doing. An
example of this might be “This is my Gonti,
Canny Acquisitor rogue deck. It’s a theft
deck that wants to hit people with evasive
Rogues to steal cards, and eventually pump
up my rogues for the win. It’s bracket 3.”
First thoughts, this is fine, a very normal
opinion to have and a reasonable suggestion. I
already do some version of this, as do most people
I play with in public. At least half the time
when I’m reading the commander of a stranger I’m
playing against, or when I make a comment about
it, they’ll drop me a basic pitch for how they’re
using the commander and what their deck is doing.
The only critique I might have of this
idea is that it’s maybe a little odd to
have a pitch like this rehearsed word for word and
delivered like some sort of theatrical monologue,
but the broader point about communication
is good—or so I thought. This post was not
all that popular on r/EDH—63 upvotes
and 89 comments at time of recording,
with some comments critical of the idea
getting more upvotes than the post itself.
[Arcosa] Revealing what your deck does by
playing it sounds way more fun to me than
everyone giving a synopsis on how the
game is gonna go before it even starts.
[Quips] You don't need to tell other
players your deck’s life story,
an interesting fact, or even a basic
strategy. Once everyone chooses their
commanders and commanders are revealed,
they can deduce strategies from there.
[Rebell] Leaving some mystery to the
game is fun. It means we can play to
figure out each other's weakness
instead of basically being told.
[Snail] In the broader scheme of things,
this doesn’t matter. A modestly visible
reddit post attracted some people with opinions I
disagree with who then got a handful of upvotes,
big whoop. However, I can’t get this
line of thinking out of my brain,
and these opinions are similar to comments I’ve
received on my channel. There seems to be a large
online faction of commander players who think
this way, who treat commander as some sort of
detective game where a large part of the gameplay
is figuring out what’s going on in opposing decks,
or alternatively as some sort of show that
you wouldn’t want to spoil the ending of.
So, I’m going to take this post as a jumping
off point to talk about that broad faction,
this group of players that I find fascinating,
and I’m going to see if I can figure out what
motivates their thinking, why they’re like this,
and if there’s anything to the vision of commander
they strive after. As a disclaimer—this video is
more conceptual and social-theory-oriented than
most of what I make, so I’d recommend treating
it as some fun ideas to chew on rather than cold
hard facts to destroy the libs with or whatever.
Though this is a sort of a soft response to The
Trinket Mage’s video about me in April, so I guess
this can be cold hard facts to destroy him with.
[Trinket narrating]
EDH is typically a casual format, which simply
means that players aren’t necessarily expected
to try as hard as they can to win, either in-game
or in deckbuilding. This is challenging for people
because, in any sort of game setting, a lot of
people will instinctually look for some sort
of goal to optimize toward. We can see this
play out in something like D&D—role-playing
games are even more casual than casual EDH
in a lot of ways, but many players will
still put a lot of effort into making their
characters as powerful as possible in combat.
This is kind of pointless on a party level since
the DM can literally make combats easier or harder
on a whim to suit the players, and even harder in
a way that’s targeted to a specific player. Still,
the power level of a character remains a thing
that people optimize because they need a goal
while building out a character sheet—something
needs to motivate the decisions being made. The
same goes for EDH—people will create goals in the
deckbuilding process, and one of those goals will
frequently be making a deck that is good under
some set of criteria, at least if you’re not one
of the mythical bracket 1 gamers. So that will
be a part of deckbuilding, but what about in
games? There are all sorts of skills tested in a
competitive 1v1 magic environment—turn sequencing,
mastery of a given decklist, assessment of
opposing threats, probabilistic thinking,
playing to outs, and so on. A 1v1 Magic tournament
will stress-test a player’s skills in all these
things to the limit, and in many cases games will
be won and lost by the collective weight of a
lot of tiny decisions. As in deckbuilding, EDH’s
casual nature makes things trickier in the sense
that winning isn’t as dominant a goal, and plays
that are suboptimal in the strict sense might not
necessarily be considered misplays in the same
way they are in 60 card formats. As a result
of this fact, a lot of EDH players subconsciously
go looking for something to replace some of these
competitive skills, and in a format as diverse
as EDH, a very common substitute is knowledge.
A certain subset of EDH players seem almost
obsessed with knowing as many possible plays
their opponents can do as possible. This is
especially true for players playing at a level
with sudden ways to win, where not being able to
recognize a combo piece or central enabler for an
opponent’s deck can rapidly lead to a game loss.
Whether it’s as an outlet for an underutilized
competitive instinct or as a trauma response to
getting OTK’d one too many times, being able to
shrewdly navigate the ins and outs of opposing
plays and figure out how threatening a particular
card is within the entire landscape of the EDH
format is a skill that a lot of players have built
up. This is especially true for commanders—a lot
of commanders have a handful of cards they pair
pretty powerfully with, and having it locked away
in your dome what those cards might be for a given
commander can give you a leg up in determining
the possibilities for what an opponent might be
doing. And, if we assume that most decks with a
given commander will be somewhat similar, having
an encyclopedic knowledge of commanders and what
their typical decks look like can actually serve
as somewhat of a replacement for rule 0. I don’t
even need to have a conversation with my opponent,
all I need to do is see that Teysa pull up and I’m
already squaring up for some Ashnod’s Altar BS.
So this is a skill that a lot of players have
put effort into honing, whether consciously or
unconsciously, and it shouldn’t be surprising
that a lot of them want to use this skill. And,
for a player who has spent a lot of time around
various magic cards and is fully engaged in a
game, it’s not hard to imagine this being a lot of
fun. I see my opponent play a Blood Artist effect,
and I start to look for possible loops, think
about what sac outlets and supporting pieces are
in-color for my opponent. I see a Karn’s Bastion
hit the board, and start trying to deduce what
counters are soon to pop into existence. I see
an opponent with two lands untapped on my turn
and I try to figure out what sorts of disruption
they might be able to put together with red, blue,
and white mana. I would be lying if I claimed
that the description of the commander format
I just described doesn’t sound fun—it’s
appealing to play a game like that. So,
what’s the problem? Surely there’s nothing
wrong with people enjoying the format this way.
[Elk narrating]
Comedic name-calling aside, this is my most
basic issue with the vision of the commander
format I just presented. I dedicated a full
20 minute video to this topic last summer,
but here’s the short version. The EDH format has
become effectively the onboarding format of paper
Magic, the way new players get into the game and
the way a lot of them continue to play the game.
This is cool in a lot of ways, and there’s one
especially new-player-friendly element at the
heart of the commander format—it doesn’t have a
meaningful metagame. You don’t have to learn the
opposing decks you might be facing and figure
out what decks can fare well against those,
and more importantly you won’t have to worry
that your deck will be too weak to face the
competition. This is wonderful for creativity in
deckbuilding—60 card magic typically relegates
“creativity” or “brewing” to players with a
relatively strong grasp of a given format,
but since EDH lacks a metagame or set power
level, players of any skill can innovate and
create something of their own rather than needing
to netdeck. This is an undoubtedly nice feature,
but on the flip side, this lack of a metagame
ironically also poses an entirely different
set of challenges onto players that aren’t
found in a competitive 1v1 format. You can’t
learn the 4 most common decks you’ll be playing
because there are thousands of possible decks
you might find yourself facing. This might be
manageable in a playgroup with unchanging decks,
but playing out in the wild with strangers is
a whole different story. Any set of 4 EDH decks
will likely have more than 200 unique nonland
cards, which is a fair amount to learn if the
decks are unchanging, and an ongoing gauntlet for
newer players in a public setting where each game
might present dozens of new cards. I think most
of us have been in a game among strangers where
it becomes clear that one or more players are
checked out from what opponents are doing,
fatigued by the process of keeping up with all
the new cardboard that’s hitting the table.
So that’s the case I’m trying to present here.
EDH has 3x the opponents and often around 10x
the number of unique cards in opposing decks
as compared to 1v1 formats. There are 30,000
cards legal in the format now, and thousands of
brand new cards entering the format every year.
Each deck tends to play far more permanents than
are seen in 1v1 formats due to the higher life
totals and the multiplayer aspect of things,
and the result is that boards rapidly clog up
with assorted permanents for players to keep
track of. The information density of EDH is
untouched by any other widely-played format, and
that is a feature about it that we need to keep
in mind when we’re playing it. All of this is
why I find the “knowledge competition” version
of casual EDH frustrating, and seek to reduce it
as much as possible. And that’s as somebody who
is probably better equipped to threat analyze
than at least 80% of EDH players—it’s not that
I can’t figure out how potentially game-ending
a sequencing of opposing plays is on the fly,
it’s that I don’t think that should necessarily
be a constant task expected of all EDH players.
The game of figuring out what my opponent’s deck
does is just not one I think is beneficial to
have at the center of the EDH format. There are
even plenty of days that I personally wish to
avoid this part of the format, to kick my feet
back and focus on resolving my cascade triggers
instead of Sherlock-Holmesing my way to what the
white-knuckled powergamer across the table is
packing. But still. With all that said, I could
see somebody thinking that I’m throwing out the
baby with the bath water here. Sure, knowing a
rough outline of what opposing decks are doing
might reduce the mental load of the format
and make it more approachable for all people,
but what about the theatricality of it? What about
surprises and zany moments and unexpected twists?
[BDD Narrating]
A fairly common mistake that’s made among
newer game masters in a role playing game
like D&D or Pathfinder is placing too much
importance on their own predetermined plot,
and especially trying to create plot moments that
will generate a notable reaction in players. This
strange hilltop village? It’s actually
on the back of a massive creature. Whoa,
dude! Now you’re telling me these past 5 sessions
have been playing out in the mind of Jackson the
Frost Dragon during his fight with this world’s
real enemy, Lord Xyrox? What a revelation!
This isn’t to say that creating unexpected plot
beats is never a good idea, but it’s not a good
thing to dump most of your effort into as a GM or
make a load-bearing centerpiece of your campaign,
because it’s not really what makes a multiplayer
RPG fun. Most players aren’t showing up to
sessions to be recited your half-baked book idea,
they’re there for collaborative storytelling,
for experiencing funky situations outside the
realm of reality, for throwing around die rolls
and getting to play with the fun character they
crafted. It might feel good to imagine your big
reveal getting the same emotional response as
some other big moment that arises organically,
but that’s not necessarily going to happen.
At this point you’re probably asking,
what does this have to do with EDH, Alex? Well,
a very similar dynamic takes place there. I
dedicated a whole video to this topic about
a year ago, but the basic idea there was that
there are some inherent and unavoidable problems
with decks that like to win in some grandiose way.
I have a deck that wins by getting three Fiend
Hunters in play at the same time to fiend-hunt
each other indefinitely and cobble together an
ETB-based win from there. I also brewed a list
with the goal of casting Rograkh an arbitrarily
large number of times before Jeska-ing all three
of my opponents for an arbitrarily large amount
of damage. These are undoubtedly flashy as far as
wincons go, and they really play into the “showing
off” side of EDH, the part of the format that
is driven by the desire to have strangers ooh
and ah at the cool things your deck is doing.
In principle this is fine, but in reality you tend
to get the desired response a lot less than you’d
expect with this kind of deck. EDH is already
full of combo decks that can pull off cool,
explosive wins, and even if your
combo deck is a cut above the rest,
it’s still putting together a handful of
cards that abruptly end the game. Effectively,
this sort of deck ends up being more fun
to build than to play—it’s fun to build
and tune a deck that does something wacky and
unusual, but something being fun to think about,
fun to theorize, and fun to hear described as
a concept doesn’t necessarily make it fun in an
actual game. Because that’s what EDH is—a game.
It’s not a museum of cool card interactions, it’s
not a collaborative art installation, it’s not a
competition to see who can do the wackiest thing,
it’s a game with players and pieces and goals.
It’s not identical to a conventional board game,
obviously—in the best of times I’d argue
it can be much more interesting than your
average medium-complexity board game—but it
should be a lot closer to that than it is to
reading off a list of the most interesting
things you can do with Second Harvest.
So that’s my precautionary note about funky combo
decks, and it also applies to any deck whose main
gameplan is a bit of a one-trick pony, such as a
deck that is built to cascade into a particular
threat every game. Still, I’m guessing that
argument probably isn’t all that persuasive
to a lot of people in the context of pregame
conversations. Sure, a deck that plans to win in
some sudden, dramatic way shouldn’t be hiding its
gameplan, but what about cool plays that aren’t
game-winning? Are you just asking me to cough up
all my deck’s secrets for my opponents to see, to
spill the beans on my decks’ cool intricacies? If
I’m to be totally honest, I don’t quite know how
to respond to this sort of question, because to me
it’s a clear indication that the person saying it
and myself are really not on the same page about
the terms of the discussion. So, let’s get on the
same page—what is the purpose of a conversation
at or near the start of a game where players
describe their decks? Two things. One, it’s a
rule zero conversation—anytime you’re mentioning
the bracket of your deck, how it plans to win,
and what its most powerful plays are, you’re
giving your opponents the opportunity to decide
if they want to play against that. This is why
I find combo decks that win in some cool way the
most relevant example—even if you’d quite like to
keep your cool combo a secret to put on some sort
of dramatic performance for anybody watching, when
you’re playing that sort of deck you really should
be making it clear to your opponents that that’s
what you’re doing. This could be as simple as
saying “I’m playing a deck with a combo win that
frequently happens around turn 7,” which gives
your opponents the tools they need to decide if
they want to be in this game with a moderate speed
combo deck. In contrast to this, a deck whose
cool thing isn’t a combo win might not have this
sort of relevant obligation in the rule 0 phase.
The other purpose of a start-of-game conversation
is getting players calibrated about what’s to
come, and I actually think of this as the more
important purpose. A lot of players will be okay
playing against a somewhat spicy deck so long as
they get some idea of what to expect and what to
watch out for. With my most powerful deck, my
Francisco Malcolm deck, I’ll generally tell my
opponents that my deck is fast, with frequent turn
5 wins, and that it usually wins with Time Sieve,
and with these two things in their pocket
my opponents will have a decent idea of
what to watch out for and the tools to make
strategic decisions against my deck. Likewise,
with my Sharuum deck I’ll tell my opponents that
my deck is a control deck built around Astral
Slide. This is an exceptionally short description
of my deck that leaves dozens of cool interactions
unmentioned, but it communicates the two most
important facts my opponents might want to know:
that my deck will be able to exert more
leverage over the game the longer it goes,
and that flickering permanents is a central
part of my gameplan. Performing this sort of
“calibration” is a good practice because
EDH is fundamentally a social format,
and one where players should be thinking about
their opponents’ decks and strategizing the best
way to navigate around what their opponents are
playing. If players don’t have basic information
on their opponents’ decks, they’re in the
dark. Who’s the threat now? Who might be
the threat later? What on board currently
is threaten-ing? If you’re struggling to
make simple decisions because you lack basic
information about the decks present, a whole
lot of the depth and the skill of the EDH format
is stripped out, with a lot of luck replacing it.
This also ties in with the information density
of the format—in his video about me in April,
The Trinket Mage responded to my arguments about
the complexity of the format with a game show.
He gave me a set of cards played with a specific
commander, and asked if I could tell why the given
card was in the given deck. As an exercise to
devote my full attention to, this was kinda fun,
but the issue here is that a real commander game
would have a bunch of that sort of exercise, PLUS
threat assessing between different opponents, PLUS
playing one’s own deck, PLUS PLUS PLUS reading a
bunch of new cards if you’re not somebody who’s
already deeply embedded in the commander format.
In the context of all that extra stuff, having
the slightest leg up by knowing a couple key
elements of opposing decks can really help in
not screwing up critical threat assessments.
All of this brings me back to the people saying
“What, you want me to spill my deck’s every secret
for you?” If I’m to treat this as an entirely
good faith question, I would respond like this:
“Hi people! No, you don’t need to do that.
Here’s a flowchart!” Is the part of your deck
you’re thinking about a powerful wincon for you?
If yes, maybe consider disclosing that. If not,
is the part of your deck you’re thinking about
something you’d describe as your core gameplan
in a way that’d be helpful to decisionmaking
for somebody playing against your deck? If yes,
consider disclosing that. If not, you’re good!
We’re talking about a 10 second or less pitch,
you obviously don’t need to spill the beans
about a cool side synergy chilling deep in
your 99. But you shouldn’t need to hide
the main gameplan of your deck or conceal
the most powerful wincon. To put it bluntly, if
giving somebody a synopsis of what your deck does
ruins your experience playing it, it wasn’t
all that interesting a deck to begin with.
In all of this, I’ve also been dancing around
a final group of players: the people who think
deception is a critical part of the commander
format. This is not generally a group of players I
have a high opinion of, though to be fair some of
it might be a sort of trauma response to playing
with assholes. Some people in the reddit thread
that inspired this video mentioned concealing what
their deck is pre-game so opponents don’t
try to switch to a deck that counters it,
which would be a fair consideration if you
accept that people treating you like shit is
something you’re okay with in a commander game.
But it shouldn’t be—commander is a social format,
and if other people take pregame communication
as an opportunity to be an antisocial bully
that’s a problem with them, not a problem with
communication as a concept. There’s also another
group of players who specifically try to trick
their opponents as a strategic play, trying to
sneak through wins specifically taking advantage
of opponents lacking knowledge of their deck. This
is admittedly a spectrum—there are lesser versions
of this like sandbagging plays and playing the
small bean with a lategame centered deck, and
while I personally don’t really care for this
sort of table engagement I understand that it’s
naturally going to be a part of a multiplayer,
social format. But players doing the more serious
versions of this—downplaying an obviously busted
board to somebody who doesn’t know any better,
pretending that a powerful centerpiece card is
some normal filler, and otherwise skating
by on their opponents lack of experience,
knowledge, or focus—this behavior is toxic to
any sort of casual format, and if you need to
do this to win my natural assumption is that
you’re not very good at Magic: the Gathering.
[Ian Narrating]
This video has been kind of meandering, and
has involved various different arguments in
favor of open communication, as well as
various arguments against the opposite
sort of table behavior. Despite this, I’m less
singleminded about this than you might think,
and there are some pretty reasonable arguments for
less table disclosure that I’ve heard in the past.
One of these is that treating less experienced
players as full-fledged commander players, as
well as not trying to baby them with lots of extra
treatment, is both more respectful and a better
learning environment for a lot of players. This
is an idea I’m sympathetic to—different players
do well in different environments, and a situation
where everybody else is playing with the kiddie
gloves on might not necessarily be the ideal one
for learning the format, depending on the player.
Although, I think this reasoning can work the
other way as well—when I play a very impactful
card, I’ll generally emphasize it to the table,
oftentimes saying something like “I attempt to
cast Captivating Crew.” To me, this is saying to
my opponents “I’m doing something that, of course,
you all as sensible players who know my gameplan
might want to stop, and I’m respectfully giving
you the opportunity to do so.” Same reasoning of
respecting my opponents’ capabilities of players,
but in this instance it leads to more table
communication rather than less. Regardless of
where you go with this idea, it’s important to
remember different players learn better under
different circumstances, and we should never
assume we have the one-size-fits-all solution
to teaching, playing with, and showing
respect to less experienced players.
A related argument that I find compelling is that
over-emphasizing rule 0 as a part of the game can
encourage a mindset of fear and avoidance in
newer players rather than the curiosity and
openness to experience that arguably make for a
better experience in commander. If players are
immediately told to watch out for stax, to avoid
mana denial, to fear infect, to not play mill,
to disrespect discard, and to ask for no goad
in their games, suddenly you end up with a bunch
of players who exist in echo chambers and avoid
experiences they find uncomfortable. The Trinket
Mage has discussed how newer players in his games
have had relatively neutral reactions to Humility
of all cards, seeming curious about this card
they’d never seen before more than anything else.
While I don’t think I’d try this with one of
the most oppressive stax pieces in the game,
the broader point is an interesting one—players
are subtly influenced by the ways other people
react to cards, and when they haven’t been taught
to hate and fear a card, they’ll be more engaged
and more prepared to problem solve when playing
against it. This is also part of why I care more
about the establishing expectations part of a
pregame conversation than I care about the rule
0 part. It’s valid for players to not want to play
against a particular thing, but I’d rather play
in a landscape where the list of hard no’s for
players is smaller, and an alternative to keeping
something like stax or combos out of a game
altogether is disclosing those things up front and
allowing players the time to prepare themselves
for those things rather than getting blindsided
later. As general practices, your opponents
should know about the most threatening parts
of your deck because that’s the part they might
want to strategize against. Your opponents should
know the strongest wincon in your deck not just so
they can decide if they want to play against it,
but also so they can decide how they should
be playing against you once the game starts.
These suggestions might feel frustrating for
the people used to grabbing at every strand
of advantage and playing close to the chest for
a better shot at winning, but I can promise you
they’ll make for better commander games and a
healthier commander ecosystem in the long term.
The final takeaway I’d want to impart here is
simply that the EDH format being accessible or
good for new players or for players who play less
often or so on—none of these considerations are
binaries. I will happily admit that much of the
EDH format’s information density is inherent to
its basic construction. The number of players,
the deck size, the higher life totals—all of
these things are factors in producing overwhelming
games for players. The lazy response to noticing
this is to throw in the towel before you’ve even
begun. EDH is complicated, so it’s pointless to
take any steps to make it more approachable or
more enjoyable for a wider range of players,
a coward might say. The issue with this sort of
statement is that the commander format, along
with most other things in life, is not a binary.
It can always be modulated one way or another—even
if commander’s inherent features mean that
some number of players will struggle with the
information density, there are still things we as
players can do to decrease the number of players
who feel overwhelmed or fatigued, or make the
experience of commander more enjoyable even for
the players who aren’t keeping up perfectly well.
Solutions should be viewed not based on whether
they fix all problems, but rather whether
they solve more problems than they create.
There are undoubtedly some solutions that don’t
pass that test. Pushing players to run simpler
and more conventional decks. Pressuring new
players to play a different format instead
of commander. Asking Wizards of the Coast to
get heavily involved in fixing commander’s
information density problem. These are all
things that you could argue might help,
but they leave open the potential for all sorts
of negative side effects. What isn’t loaded with
potential negative side effects is talking
to your opponents. You don’t need to share
your deck’s life story or list out every card
or any other piece of hyperbole thrown out by
some denizen of the internet. My video a year
ago spent a while going over suggestions so
I’ll keep it brief and simple here. Treat your
opponents like people you’re playing a game with,
and give them the information they need to
engage with your deck on a basic level. If
you’re worried that 10 seconds of talking about
your deck is going to ruin its fun surprises,
that’s probably a good indicator that the
surprises aren’t actually fun and that all you
have on your hands is a gimmick that you and/or
everyone you know will be sick of in approximately
27 seconds. Finally, it’s okay if you enjoy
any of the versions of information-limited
commander I’ve been complaining about in
this video—I even see the appeal of some
aspects of that style. At the end of the day,
the biggest takeaway here should simply be to
keep audience in mind—what’s fun for you isn’t
inherently going to be fun for other people,
what you can handle cognitively isn’t inherently
going to be handled as well by other people,
and what works for one table might not work for
all tables. Casual EDH is a format inherently
built on compromise and collaboration, and leaning
into that will only lead to having more fun.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to Archidekt
for supporting the channel. I recently did a
deck review on my second channel, and the flexible
UI of Archidekt was so helpful for both helping
me analyze decks and helping me display their
different elements. A link to all of my decks
is in the description. Also, shout out to all of
these people for being cool creators and lending
their vocal talents in this video. A link to each
of their channels is in the description. Finally,
thanks to my Patrons and YouTube members
for their ongoing support of everything I
do here. I have some extra thoughts about how
brackets interact with rule 0 that didn’t make
sense to put anywhere in this video, so
I’ve tossed those in a three-minute video
for supporter. I wanted to get this bad boy out
the door so that bit’s not quite finished yet,
but keep your eyes peeled for that, it’ll
be out in the next couple days. Saloob out.